foreign
[Music]
who really gives a crap about law isn't
this the most bizarre delivery
Donald Trump Jr
delivered a manic episode
this prosecution isn't based on facts
or the law
[Music]
isn't based on facts
facts how would he know that they'll all
be damned the Constitution be damned
you're right speed Dan because you know
when you hate America what difference
does it make junior is just ranting
uncontrollably the hot take on Twitter
was that these guys are trying to do
this
I've never seen Junior like this and
I've seen Junior pretty hopped up
bullshovic style I've never seen Junior
like this and I've seen Junior pretty
hopped up
I don't know I've never seen Junior like
this and I've seen Junior pretty hopped
up full of style I've never seen Junior
like this and I've seen Junior pretty
hopped up pure witch hunter
who really gives a crab about law when
you're weaponizing your office and where
everyone there agrees with you
foreign
ERS there don't know what the hell to do
about this because even they realize
that it's insane
just a bizarre bizarre show all together
[Music]
Bolshevik Style
Trump was doing this with his personal
toilets
[Music]
what on Earth is going on with Trump
toilets
[Music]
Trump's White House toilet
would be clogged
clogged
with documents that Donald Trump was
flushing down the toilet
is this the explanation is this the
explanation a big massive dumps
[Music]
ten times
United Church thank you very much
elements and bathrooms ladies and
gentlemen do not adjust your television
it is really 2023 and for the first time
in history a president is being indicted
and will face criminal charges yes
Ulysses
Ulysses S Grant once drove drunk or
something yes Franklin Pierce something
or other this is the first criminal
indictment for a former president and by
the way can you imagine a better day for
this to happen than when I'm trying to
get the right wing lunatics to pay
attention to something other than my
recently deleted tweet I was on the
phone with Brian Tyler Cohen yesterday
or the day before and I said to him I
was like you know what would be really
great right now to take the attention
off of my stupid to deleted tweet if we
could somehow get Trump indicted and we
laughed and then of course we cried and
you know
um and then it happened ladies and
gentlemen and then it happened this is
all just such great news such great news
maybe I was wrong maybe prayer does work
after all
no but in all seriousness what about
Hunter Biden's laptop right I mean where
is that laptop and why is it that they
won't show it to us
um
folks folks folks we are all here
welcome to everybody I'm aware that some
of my new haters are trying to get my
attention and YouTube chat as if I'm
gonna give them any attention I don't
care about you guys we're Trump's been
indicted your great orange leader is
getting indicted all right let's let's
look at what we know so far New York
Times reporting updated two minutes ago
grand jury votes to indict Donald Trump
in New York by the way
this might only be the first of many
many
indictments there is a sense in the
legal and political community that many
prosecutors are ready to go but they
don't want to be the first but now that
the floodgates have been opened now that
a straw has broken the proverbial
camel's back
this may be the first of many Mr Trump
will be the first former president to
face criminal charges the precise
charges are not yet known but the case
is focused on a hush money payment to a
porn star during his 2016 campaign
a Manhattan grand jury voted to indict
Donald Trump on Thursday for his role in
paying hush money to a porn star
according to five people with knowledge
of the matter a historic or an historic
development that will shake up the 2024
presidential race and forever Mark him
he wanted to be remembered he will be
remembered as the nation's first former
president to face criminal charges an
indictment will be announced in the
coming Days by then prosecutors working
for Alvin Bragg will have asked Trump to
surrender and face arraignment Trump is
going to be arrested he will surrender
and he will be arraigned ladies and
gentlemen wow
wow wow it is not a dream it is really
happening it is really happening now
Will trump serve prison time no he won't
uh but could this completely derail his
campaign yes it absolutely could so an
incredible and momentous week in so many
different ways Sean Hannity attacking me
last night Donald Trump Jr attacking me
two nights ago and now daddy is getting
arrested
wow
wow it's I'm still trying to hold I
might have to actually hold on a second
here
wow
what a day
let's see what's happening on CNN
if we can unmute write him uh four
crimes in this matter now obviously it's
not election interference but my point
is that while we do not know how voters
will respond to this we have seen time
and again Trump able to portray himself
a victim for his core supporters and use
that as a moment for them to guys
completely normal way to drink water
pour it for him and that's what he has
been hoping to do it's what we saw him
do uh down in Waco Kristen Holmes was
down there covering that
um it's what we've seen him do on his
social media for the last several weeks
as they've been anticipating this
announcement so the Trump's team is to
actually employ this as a political
tactic while also yeah of course Trump's
going to try to spin it in his favor
here's something pretty funny this is
this is so funny Fox News is struggling
to find a way to spin the indictment
this I have to hear he's he is an OG
right I mean he is a badass if he's got
a mugshot you might go right into it and
the thing is I I you know his pull the
Law and Order people are saying being
arrested is good now oh boy guys I don't
think I don't think I can do I mean the
the Law and Order people now are like no
getting arrested those are creds man on
the street those are creds Obama numbers
have gone up with this I just think this
is good good to make sure he he is gonna
be on the ticket yeah
oh man these people have hit rock bottom
these people have truly hit rock bottom
all right
um let's see
the booking officer looked at me with
tears in his eyes and said Mr President
it's been an honor after taking my mug
shot yeah then everybody saluted as you
can imagine
um let's see here Charlie Kirk
the political Rubicon has been crossed
there's no going back okay so now let me
be serious for for let me be serious for
a moment
um
over the next couple of hours that we're
going to be together here
I hope there are no riots
I hope there are no riots it has seemed
as though the Trump acolytes are not
hugely motivated to go and Riot right
now
but I don't know because Charlie Kirk is
riling them up let's see what's
happening on Newsmax how are they
spinning this I
yeah okay no no I actually I that I I
didn't think about the odds the way you
just did that's why you're a good
attorney and I'm a pundit that makes a
lot more sense the way you just put it I
get it I mean I'd rather play the odds
because you just need one to get that
Reasonable Doubt and I have a feeling
that that wow folks if you're already
talking about Trial strategy
before we even know the charges things
are going to get very crazy kid to the
jury usually cases do get to the jury
but there is a very serious statute of
limitations issue a very complicated one
in some ways oh God it could end up
throwing out the indictment I don't know
what the gentle too but it's oh is folks
we don't even know the charges they're
talking about the indictment being
invalid don't don't you think that they
would know about the statute of
limitations dear God uh we'll we'll see
you in just a few seconds once again
breaking news a former president Trump
officially indicted according to New
York Times yeah Trump will now the New
York Times is trustworthy huh and to be
indicted on criminal charges in American
history this in relation to this
so-called uh payment to it's not a
so-called payment it's a payment uh
let's see what's happening over on Fox
News oh Jesse Waters oh my God
something feels terrible
you know GOP candidate Vivek Ram is
wamija
Jesse something about this just feels
terrible to Jesse guys I feel great
American for the ruling party to use
police power uh to arrest and I can't
read the rest but
if you thought if you thought the system
was rigged already
yeah
wow they don't know what to do and what
to say on Fox News I mean quite
literally they have no idea what's even
happening it needs to be very clear
about how this got upgraded what the
exact process was what the we need to
know about process suit folks super
chats are dumping in I love this Austin
says that canceling of David is about to
lose a lot of steam if you're just
joining us I was on the phone
telephonically with Brian Tyler Cohen
the other day and we were just talking
about like how long is this cancel
campaign against me going to last and
all of this stuff and I said to him do
you think maybe we could get Trump
indicted in the next day because that
would really help me like very much
personally and uh he's we just laughed
but now it's happening now here is a
legitimate question we have to update
the promo code to indicted I think that
that's absolutely fair and I'm going to
tell you right now memberships are
dumping in so quickly I can't even
follow it one
two three four five six
seven eight uh I am I am going to update
the coupon code you know for about six
months now the coupon code has been in
diet
and it's been like a 50 discount we do
have to change this to indicted at this
point in time and I'm gonna do that
right now coupon code
create new
the new coupon code ladies and gentlemen
I think that that's just it's a perfect
perfect idea as we stand by at the
courthouse
indicted and let's make it
let's make it a really really good
discount okay here we go and publish I
will update it over here indicted and
it'll just give me a I have to flush the
cash or the toilets however you describe
it all right the coupon code is indicted
Fox News in shambles we two have played
a key role in connecting Cohen and
Daniels The National Enquirer bought the
rights to two stories of women claiming
they had affairs with Trump but never
published the those stories a practice
called catch and kill now during a rally
in Waco Saturday Trump who is again
running for president claimed he's under
investigation for something that is not
a crime not a misdemeanor not an affair
Trump's really a legal expert isn't he
expect to get more details on the
charges in the coming days the Trump's
attorneys will likely negotiate with the
district attorney some sort of plan to
have the former president surrender yes
she doesn't know what when he would
surrender now Trump is also facing three
other okay wait a second day Kona I
don't know where the hell that's coming
from Kona wins every time what the hell
oh it's over here oh my God
could we like mute that geez that's
annoying huh right
okay Laura thank you let's go to Fox
News Chief legal correspondent and
anchor Fox News Sunday Shannon bream
good evening Shannon just moments ago
Eric Trump relaying that this is a third
world prosecutorial prosecutorial
misconduct reacting to the word of the
indictment uh it is that he's getting
arrested guys and so it's just not fair
we'll expect it at 5 28 on Thursday
after what we've been seeing in recent
days yeah I think you're right it is the
first of its kind this is the first
you're indicting a full
folks do you have any idea the level of
cope that we are going to be seeing over
the next several hours I don't I don't
think I've ever covered anything like
this I really do I mean it's it is
stunning stunning stunning stuff
um let's see a little bit of what's
happening on CNN everybody stand by
this is CNN breaking news
if you're just joining us I'm Wolf
Blitzer we're here in the situation room
we're following truly historic major
breaking news sources now tell CNN that
a New York Grand Jury has voted to
indict the former president of the
United States Donald Trump this is the
first time in U.S history the first time
in U.S history that criminal charges
have been filed against anyone who has
served as president of the United States
the charges coming after the
investigation of hush Money Paid to
former adult film star Stormy Daniels to
cover up her own when Wolf Blitzer has
already lost his voice this early in the
story you know it's going to be a very
very crazy crazy night folks in the in
the chat asking for free memberships
davidpackman.com free membership
historic super chats are dumping in one
two
three
four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven twelve twelve more people using
today's historic coupon code indicted
indicted I can't even follow what's
happening on Twitch people are just
losing their minds over this Jake says
via Super Chat sir sure I've been
waiting for this for so long I wanted to
thank you for what you do and I'm sad to
hear about the hate being thrown at you
please keep doing what you do I want to
say thanks to Andrew who just gifted 10
YouTube subscriptions to people people
are rejoicing it is stunning what is
happening uh Andrew with a 50 Super Chat
my thoughts exactly on the timing ride
the wave to National prominence you got
this uh folks it is wild I can't even
figure out what is happening here with
this with the super chats the pack has
your back says Darren yay
um
well I I just don't I don't even know
that the website can hold what's going
on if you're just joining us this is the
first ever criminal indictment of a
former president of the United States
Donald Trump is expected to negotiate a
surrender potentially a mug shot
sometime over the next week CNN is
covering it uh Fox News is covering it
they oh god Turley let's listen to the
cope
looking live at Mar-A-Lago Palm Beach
residents for the former president I
want to read just a paragraph from The
New York Times
oh my God documenting of this uh in this
story it says on Thursday the three lead
prosecutors on the Trump investigation
walked into the building where the grand
jury was sitting in the minutes before
the panel was scheduled to meet at 2 pm
one of them carried a copy of the penal
law with Post-it notes visible which was
likely used to read the criminal
statutes to the Grand jurors before they
voted about three hours later the
prosecutors walked into the court
clerk's office through a back door to
begin the process of filing the
indictment as you rightly point out
Jonathan the federal prosecutors in the
southern district of New York chose not
to go down this road with this case the
Federal Election Commission chose not to
go down this road with this case and
then Alvin Bragg himself as district
attorney when he first took office did
not put for a hold indefinitely let me
guess Turley is going to say there are
big problems with what's happening let's
see
yeah and part of the problem Brad is
that you hand Brad throw a flag on this
case which was the right thing to do
yeah and then there's two lead
prosecutors resigned in protest and one
of them took the in my view outrageous
step of writing a book about the
investigation which was still ongoing
they were the the subject of his book
was an individual who hadn't been uh
convicted uh or charged wow and so this
book really ramped up the pressure on
Brea but the other interesting thing
about this is that there's a good reason
why the Department of Justice did not
prosecute this case because it's been
down this road before right it tried a
case against former Democratic
presidential candidate John Edwards big
cope happening on Fox News CNN is
covering this let's check in brief oh
dershowitz is on the phone let's listen
weakest case I've seen in 60 years
the weakest case dershowitz has even
read about that's the whole issue of
prosecutorial discretion and it's one
thing to stretch it for a terrorism
murder charge and I'm not saying you
know assuming that this happened it's
unseemly to pay off someone when I get
that but in terms of sort of the gravity
of the offense when you've got all these
corporations with their ndas paying off
women every single day of the week
probably there's one sign while you and
I talk the sort of the whole idea that
they're going to this extreme thing and
and for I mean using prosecutorial
discretion I don't I know did they
launder the money through their lawyer
and campaign though is the question
they're like no no you know sometimes
people pay hush money sometimes there's
ndas well how about a situation that is
actually equivalent to this one how
about that
uh okay let's see Eugene says via Super
Chat that his prayers have been answered
um Tim writes to me with tears in his
eyes says what a great day for the rule
of law in America much more to be done
but today Justice matters
Quaker Ladies as we walked watch January
6th with you and it is fitting we watch
this with you too keep on keeping on
David thank you Quaker lady
thank goodness for live twitch notices
indictment watch is now over it is
indictment day
wow
um
thanks to Jody for gifting five
subscriptions uh via YouTube I really
appreciate that let me get a very quick
count I just want to update this I see
people signing up via twitch one two
three four five
six seven eight nine ten eleven twelve
thirteen fourteen fifteen sixteen
Seventeen eighteen nineteen twenty
twenty one twenty two twenty three okay
twenty three plus thirty five is fifty
eight and folks the coupon code has
changed from indict to indicted you know
why and I can't even keep up folks one
two three four five six seven eight on
the website nine ten eleven twelve
thirteen fourteen fifteen sixteen
sixteen plus fifty eight puts us at
seventy four as we stand by for more
news what are the charges what could the
charges be Darth says sup David you
hoping for a trump perp walk of course
I'm hoping for a perp walk but I'm sure
something much more dignified will be
negotiated for Trump
uh third world countries don't indict
former presidents they assassinate them
Trump is lucky considering the US's
third world nature well said Ryan
let's hope this builds momentum for
other indictments I believe it will
don't let the magamob stop you buddy
well here we are Sunil
big news says Firestar sir no one is
above the law keep up the great work
thank you sir sure sure sure
exactly all right let's take a look at
some of what we have going on here uh
and some of what is happening
um Fox News hot mic oh let's listen to
this here uh we have just gotten word
former
Trump has been indicted by a grand jury
in New York Trump was under
investigation by the DA's office for his
alleged hush money payment to adult film
star Stormy Daniels during the 2016
campaign wow uh here is Don Jr folks the
very same Don Jr who two nights ago
Unleashed a hate mob against me because
I had the audacity to say the thoughts
and prayers don't prevent shootings he
launched a hate mob against me and here
he is eyes almost completely swollen
shut calling this indictment a communist
level let's listen I was proven
even more right than I would have ever
imagined because apparently you know
Soros to back Manhattan District sorosed
backed attorney Alvin Bragg now by the
way do we care that Soros backed is
guys do we care about that or
do we not Soros backed means sore gross
gave money to a pack that helps elect
DA's all over the country one D.A they
supported
was Alvin Bragg there has been no
communication even indirectly related to
this involving Alvin do we care about
that oh we used to care about facts we
don't anymore that's fair
that's fair is actually indicting my
father so let's be clear folks please
this is
like communist level
oh guys it's too good
it's too good I'm so glad that you're
all here
oh my goodness
someone sent me this clip of myself from
earlier
Dear God
we're gonna have to put that on the uh
on the sound board all right let's
finish this listen to this clip clear
folks this is
like communist level really this is
stuff that would make Mao
Stalin
Pol Pot it would make them blush well
Trump loves all those guys
Trump last night in an interview had
nothing bad to say about she Putin and
Kim Jong-un
guess this is the type of stuff he
aspires to it's so flagrant it's so
crazed when even like the radical
leftists of the Washington Post are out
there saying it's not really based on
facts it's not really based on the lot
not really based in reality but it's a
hundred percent based on politics when
your enemies are saying that it sounds
like in the word based he's including
the letter N I've never heard that
pronunciation before
it's got to tell you everything you need
to know right now about where we are as
a country yeah we might actually hold
someone accountable God forbid Donny boy
uh all right let me do one other run
through folks are attempting to use the
coupon code indicted to celebrate what
is happening today at joinpakman.com one
two three
four five I can't even read every name
because so many people six seven eight
nine ten eleven
12 13 14. 15 16 17 and 18. 74 plus 18
what's that like a thousand no 74 plus
18 is of course 92. and we continue to
make progress here I I'm stunned I'm
stunned by what's going on friend of the
David packman show and honestly he
really is a good guy I've had private
conversations with Michael Cohen he he
was led astray he did bad things and
he'll be the first to admit it I've had
private conversations with Michael Cohen
genuinely a good guy uh congratulated me
on the birth of my daughter
um just just a good guy okay he was on
MSNBC taking a bit of a Victory lap
let's see
about my credibility from like the Danny
savalos to the elite honigs to the tarot
you know um Paula Reeves and so
everybody wants to attack Michael
Cohen's credibility right guess what if
you look to see what attorney general
Tish James said she credited me for the
investigation and now you know what all
of the all of the once again lies
misinformation disinformation
that they are throwing against me will
ultimately continue to prove that
everything you know that that what I had
provided was relevant to this
investigation I think he is absolutely
correct about that certainly about that
certainly let's look at a couple other
super chats I'm doing my best to keep up
everything Jay dead the first president
to be indicted in the history of the
United States absolutely correct
a few bucks to share in the Glee from
Dan Lauren dumping in 20 new memberships
putting us at a hundred and twelve thank
you Lauren I really appreciate that
America is back hashtag Trump for prison
um wow
wow thanks to everybody on Twitch
supporting today one two three four five
six
seven one twelve plus seven is one
nineteen let's listen a little bit here
to what's happening on CNN Donald Trump
is not necessarily good for the
Republican party and that's the larger
question that's a good point indeed
Caitlin I understand you're getting some
reaction now from the current attorneys
representing Trump oh good yeah and to
be clear he has a lot attorneys that are
representing them right now because this
is
many unpaid Aid he is facing and so
there are several here this is Alina
Haba she is the first attorney that we
have heard from in Trump's orbit she
says quote a former president a current
candidate and my friend president Donald
Trump is a victim of a corrupt and
distorted version of the American
justice system in history she says he
will be Vindicated that's Alina Haba she
is one of the attorneys that you've seen
Courthouse television representing Trump
at times of course there are many
attorneys that are representing him
there's actually quite some inviting
happening within Trump's legal team
these times is there are these different
cases that are happening the documents
case the January 6 case obviously this
one here in New York that has been a bit
removed from those that is the first
statement that we have heard from them
we're waiting to see what Trump himself
says yeah in a statement on this I mean
it's almost guaranteed that it will
include attacks on Alvin Bragg because
as we've talked to sources in Trump's
world as they've been plotting behind
the scenes preparing for this moment
that we are living in right now they
have been thinking of ways to attack
Alvin Bragg they've been looking at
statements that he's made past comments
about Trump of course he's appeared on
CNN a few times looking at those very
closely because they obviously want to
try as often you saw happen with Robert
Taylor I'm seeing a lot of the same
questions in the chat so let me tell
everybody what's going on here are the
main questions everybody's asking number
one
what are the charges have not been
released yet they are still being
written up number two
um when Will trump be arrested slash
arraigned we don't yet know
three Will trump be handcuffed I think
probably not I think part of the
negotiation will be no although Trump
last week or the week before said he
would like to be handcuffed many many
questions still to be answered many many
questions let's keep looking at some of
the cope okay let's uh see uh oh here's
that clip of Jesse Waters saying it just
feels terrible this cannot stand
feel right but do facts care about your
feelings Jesse I'm trying to remember do
they say facts do care about your
feelings or facts don't I'm trying to
remember it's not hard to remember one
thing feels terrible
you know right Jesse feels terrible
I never went to law school so I'm gonna
respectfully disagree with Trey Gowdy
there you go I think that's about all we
need to hear
um Jesse Waters feel sorry for Trump
let's see what else we get here
this is wild wild stuff
this is this is really something
um
oh is this are they
are the good liars already interviewing
people about this this I have to say we
are here in Laguna Hills California at a
random in and out parking lot where I
guess Donald Trump's most loyal uh
supporters there are tens of them have
gathered to protest his impending
indictment how many people do you think
are here I don't know maybe 50 on and
off okay yeah it looks like yeah maybe
20 maybe
pretty good for rain I think if it truly
does something illegal it would be bad
but why his lawyer gave her some money
to not say anything oh this is from this
is from a couple weeks ago okay got it
got it hey guys George Anthony devolder
Santos is disturbed about the indictment
yeah okay so anyway let's keep going and
see what else we have Jim Jordan calling
it outrageous
uh
what else do we have here Greg Gutfeld
giddy over the party of Law and Order
having a nominee with a mug shot okay we
looked at that earlier Lauren bobert
breaking Trump has been indicted this is
another political Witch Hunt targeting
the people's president which people
which people someone off camera on Fox
Says as they break the news I
didn't quite hear that in the in that
video earlier let's listen just gotten
word former president Donald Trump has
been indicted okay it's very faint it's
very faint but it is there we are
finally finally finally getting what we
all knew was coming if you care about
that's exactly right law and auto it is
indeed happening uh Charlie Kirk the
political Rubicon has been crossed okay
very very good let's get back over to
CNN for people in the chat
if you become aware
of a feed that is for example monitoring
Mar-A-Lago or if protests start to build
I would like to be made aware of that I
do want to check right side broadcasting
they sometimes will stream adject trash
that's what I call it whoa
but they don't seem to be live right now
Mar-A-Lago live let's just see
if we have anything
no
seems like things are pretty calm right
now and that's the way I hope it stays
to be perfectly clear
uh
uh yeah
I'm not seeing anything else I do want
to see
where NBC is actually wait a second live
now from Fox
sometimes will
they're just at the courtroom okay
anyway let me know if that's the case uh
and and we will certainly we will
certainly look at that let me look at
some of the other super chats that are
coming in and they are coming in so
quickly
uh Jeffrey says my birthday is in two
days this is the best early birthday
gift ever I'm also praying for no
violence
I wonder if the Secret Service will
change Donnie's diapers in The Slammer
very very strong question
um just FYI for everyone President Grant
was actually the first president to be
arrested
but this moment is unprecedented yes he
was arrested but then released and not
indicted
there was no indictment is my
understanding that's really the critical
difference and then Lauren which we
already looked at love you David looking
forward to the Kumbaya Circle sinking
the singing The Star-Spangled Banner
tonight yeah if they're getting together
at Mar-A-Lago to sing Star-Spangled
Banner I definitely want to see that big
thank you to the one two three four five
six folks who just grabbed twitch Prime
subscriptions putting us at 125. I am
not against potentially opening the
phone lines people are continuing to
pour in memberships one two three four
five six seven eight nine 10 11 12.
13 14 15 16 17 18 and 19 20 21 22 125
and 22 puts us at 147. the coupon code
folks is indicted and it is because
Donald Trump has been indicted let's
listen it's the financial state
said then that he would continue this
investigation and would speak either by
coming out and saying that he was
declining a prosecution because there
wasn't the evidence where he would speak
through an indictment that we have yet
to hear from Bragg's office today but
this certainly is a turn of events I
mean Bragg's office went to trial on the
Trump organization in December they won
a conviction of tax fraud charges
against the company the company was
sentenced with a fine of 1.6 million
dollars that appeared to really embolden
the prosecution team showing that they
could win a conviction against a
trump-related entity in New York at the
grace grand jury kicked into gear in
January we saw Witnesses coming in all
these Witnesses once close to the
campaign witnesses that were like
Michael Cohen who were involved in this
deal and Witnesses including Donald
Trump's longtime friend David pecker who
was involved in these catch and kill
deals yeah he went before the grand jury
twice we saw him here on Monday he
seemed to be the grand the final witness
that the grand jury heard from he was at
the beginning of these deals he was the
one that was wrong folks are asking for
MSN NBC because there's I guess
something something happening on MSNBC
let's see if we can take a look
uh I may have to actually allow ads
which is always scary and then defeat
Biden and we're going to throw every
last one of these crooked Democrats out
of office why is this black
I can see this but it's showing up black
in OBS that's very strange
anybody know what might be going on with
that let's see if I just pause ads and
refresh that's really so it shows MSNBC
okay we can see that why is it black
because I get on my screen I can see it
some kind of protect while I didn't know
that that was possible I genuinely
didn't know that was possible well here
from the early conversations that you
and I had often with Maya and Nick
during the Trump presidency when
allegations first surfaced that's not
going to be useful to us that's not
going to be useful to us so we'll have
to see
uh we'll have to see about that let
let's listen let let's let everybody
settle down has this been done before
the Democrats Have Cheated countless
times over the decades including buying
on my cam
but weaponizing our justice system to
punish a political opponent oh Trump
just so happens to be a president of the
United States and by far the leading
Republican candidate for president has
never happened before ever
to attack Manhattan D.A Alvin Bragg he
says he was hand-picked and funded by
George Soros calling him a deuce Grace
rather than stopping the unprecedented
crime wave taking over in New York City
he's doing Joe Biden's Dirty Work
ignoring the murders and burglaries and
assaults he should be let's look at the
statement ourselves Donald Trump's
soviet-style press person has put out a
statement the statement is as follows
this is political persecution and folks
this is not a rehearsal
I see people coming in here and saying
is this is it actually happening this
time very much so truth essential this
is political persecution and election
interference at the highest level in
history from the time I came down the
golden escalator at Trump Tower and even
before I was sworn in as your president
of the United States the radical left
Democrat there's capital letters all
over this the enemy of the hard-working
men and women of this country have been
engaged in a Witch Hunt to destroy the
make America great again movement you
remember it just like I do Russia Russia
Russia the Mueller hoax Ukraine Ukraine
Ukraine impeachment hoax one impeachment
hoax two the illegal and
unconstitutional Mar-A-Lago raid and now
this the Democrats have lied cheated and
stolen in their obsession with trying to
get Trump but now they've done the
unthinkable indicting a completely
innocent person in an act of blatant
election interference never before in
our history in our nation's history has
this been done
the Democrats Have Cheated countless
times over the decades including spying
on my campaign they didn't but
weaponizing our justice system to punish
a political opponent who just so happens
to be a president of the United States
and by far the leading Republican
candidate for president has never
happened before ever I guess it goes on
on a second page Manhattan D.A Alvin
Bragg who was hand-picked and funded by
George Soros is a disgrace that's a lie
Soros donated to a pack that helps DA's
get elected
and the pack helped a bunch of
candidates including
uh brag rather than stopping the
unprecedented crime wave taking over New
York City remember the crime rates
higher in Oklahoma City than in New York
City
he's doing Joe Biden's Dirty Work
ignoring the murders and burglaries and
assaults he should be focused on this is
how Bragg spends his time I believe this
Witch Hunt will massively will backfire
massively on Joe Biden
the American people realize exactly what
the radical left Democrats are doing
here everyone can see it so our movement
and our party United in strong will
first defeat Alvin Bragg and then we
will defeat Joe Biden and we are going
to throw every last one of these crooked
Democrats out of office so we can make
America great again cool man all right
give it a shot I look forward to seeing
you try to do all that stuff thanks to
inmate Trump for gifting five
subscriptions via twitch Andrew with a
50 Super Chat says I am on the same
wavelength as Quaker lady I was with you
on January 6th here for this I don't
pray but if I did I agree please no
riots peaceful protests with crazy signs
to alienate the independence good with
that
uh quiet please sends a Super Chat green
sends a Super Chat
May the super chats outweigh the hatred
male says Eugene thank you sir power J
says it's about time Laura says I will
have to book time off to watch the trial
if it is on TV you and me both you and
me both it is an incredible incredible
day let's get an update on the copium
that is spreading
uh let's see okay this is good news this
is from
New York city mayor spokesman Fabian
Levy there are currently no public
statements or filing from D.A Bragg but
the mayor is in constant contact with
commissioner Sewell about public safety
issues affecting the city NYPD continues
to monitor all activity there are no
credible threats to the city at this
time NYPD remains prepared that's good
that is very very good news here is Don
Jr you know what I'm wondering Rumble
Donald Trump is is Junior Live right now
I think he might be live
he is live oh folks Don Jr is live right
now this I have to see he's live on
rumbles
guns are look at this
it's already glitchy we're not the issue
the coddling coercion and encouragement
of this nonsense against children and
normalizing gender affirmation surgeries
okay that's the problem folks that we
give in to each and every one of these
things
that's the problem that they'll never be
satisfied with you just accepting them
doing what they want to do as adults no
no you must capitulate you must accept
this trash is unwatchable
unwatchable here he was moments ago just
wait till they come for you because they
will like Don came for me two nights ago
people anybody remember that
we're in a battle for our existence and
this entire case
hinges on unreliable discredited
Witnesses like Stormy Daniels who I
believe owes my father a couple hundred
grand in legal fees because they lost
[Laughter]
what a lunatic Kylie J Colt with an 80
Australian dollar Super Chat says I have
nothing to say I've just supported you
since 2017. I'm an Aussie hello from
Queensland and I appreciate your
considered coverage thank you
Joseph says well he finally won a
popular vote that's right the grand jury
had a majority for once he finally got a
majority oh I think I might have to un
unless you stole that from someone else
I think I should steal that for a
beautiful tweet that would be a nice
thing uh let's see what else we have
uh
Trump is just losing it Donald Trump Jr
live reacting let's see what else he
said apparently this corrupt leftist
D.A is indicting my father on claims
that even the federal how does he stick
the letter N into father I really don't
understand that pronunciation he says
father but it sounds like there's an N
somewhere in there EA is indicting my
father on claimed did you hear that is
that
f-a-h-n-t-h-e-r that even the federal
government that spent six years trying
to put him in jail even they
didn't want to touch it
and
yet they go forward he doesn't have any
clue what's going on does he
he has no idea what's going on
um let me see if we have anything else
I guess he kept random I'm gonna go uh
make some phone calls I'm gonna look
into this further
um I'm gonna see you know what exactly
that means and you know talk to the team
uh is daddy going to prison maybe we'll
have to do a special over the weekend I
just you know I don't have much more to
say other other than the insanity of
what it is right the weak need response
from so many Republicans especially
those that you know have done a really
good job of paying influencers to make
them seem really maga maga I I get it
unfortunately that's the game and that's
what it is for them you know I don't
really care about these things they care
about what their donors ultimately I say
it's Marga making America really grifty
again because that's where they get
their money that allows them to continue
and perpetuate their careers that's why
they hate Trump because Trump doesn't
really need them it's why they've pulled
all the stops to go after Trump anybody
know what he's talking about I have no
clue what on Earth he's talking about
it's really weird
um
let's see what else if we have anything
else
Trump's foreign
all right let's uh let's check What's
Happening Here on Newsmax I'm guessing
Greta is still talking about how it's
going to be hard to convince a jury or
something but let me just throw
something out okay with those three
things I just described did any of them
have to go through any of those things
you just walk through FEC investigation
special counsels looking at it from Diaz
no no no you know why because we have
this history in this country when you're
leading the opposition political party
it's not a good idea if we start putting
each other in jail or in prison yeah
well it doesn't happen in the United
States except in cases where there is
obvious evidence as determined by the
grand jury which they did in this
particular case I think the main
narrative that I want to tell you about
right now is the following
the right is going to argue
that this is an injustice
the magats are going to insist that the
lack of justice is the indictment
but we can't allow them to distract from
the reality which is if the president is
above the law
we don't have Justice now Trump is
innocent until proven guilty he's
entitled to take a plea deal if one is
offered if he wants he's entitled to go
to trial
all of those things
but
to learn
that a president is not above the law
points towards Justice not away from it
that is the important message that we
have to take away
the smocking gun dumping in a hundred
dollar Super Chat and says a fan of the
show Good to see intelligent discussion
thank you
Tai says I'm happy about the news but
scared about what his supporters will do
I'm I'm scared as well
uh Mike says listen to you all the time
on the podcast thank you
Alan says you have more followers than
Donnie Jr I emailed some of your
sponsors yesterday greetings from
Ireland keep up the good work thank you
Alan I appreciate that very much
um
Junior with tears in his eyes I think he
said farther as he will be far away
uh
uh brass taxes man Republicans are
really upset at people being held
accountable right guys he gets his day
in court he gets his day in court okay
there was Evan this is the process the
grand jury determined there was evidence
to indict so they're indicting
and then now he has the the full legal
processes available to him and if he
wants to get some lawyers and maybe pay
them that as well folks today's coupon
code is indicted as you see it above my
head is it is no longer indict it is
indicted and people are uncontrollably
signing up on my website Kelsey is
number one two three four five six and
seven eight and nine
10 11 12. 13 14.
15 16 folks who just signed up
152 plus 16 puts us at 168. also thank
you to everyone signing up via twitch
that looks like one two three four five
six seven more people putting us at 175.
Donald Trump has issued a statement if
you're wondering when he will be
arraigned we don't yet know if you're
wondering what the charges are it has
not yet been released we are standing by
all over the place we are in Mar-A-Lago
uh at the courthouse everywhere hoping
that there will not be any violence
um here's something really funny if any
of you have been following the fact that
Sean Hannity and Don Jr and Candace
Owens have led a hate mob against me
over the last three days the timing of
this really couldn't be better here's a
voicemail saying exactly that hey Dave
what timing huh you lucky lucky dog you
yep and I'm very happy about it uh I
thought you got sandbanked
um pretty hard so I I'm just letting you
know that you got a lot of support out
here I emailed
um your advertisers just to show support
because I love you and I don't know
where I'd be without you
um
listen though the thing with Trump he's
gonna we should all be prepared he's
gonna spin this in his own favor right I
mean he's gonna come out of that
courtroom and he's going to give a lit
hilarious press conference and it's
gonna put a lot of uh you know like
these uh liberal accounts on Twitter
shouldn't say liberal but the accounts
that are like constantly frothing at
them all for his indictment so
um just be a little we should all temper
our our enthusiasm just a little bit
before as great as this is uh he's gonna
believe this guy's a street fighter is
gonna come out
um yeah and so
I hope Trump does do a press conference
after he's arraigned and I can only
imagine the insanity of what that's
going to be like I I mean it's it's hard
to even fathom how triggered he's gonna
be hey David how many big strong
powerful guys do you think it will take
to arrest the failed former president
much love from Saint Andrews Scotland
very very good question Samuel you're
thinking the right way
still alive says does anyone know why we
pronounce the word indicted the way we
do and not indicted because of the
English language being weird
David sorry to hear the threats from
Sean the rat here for you brother thanks
Abu appreciate that for the war chest
against conservatives coming to cancel
you thank you for your tireless efforts
to give us solid content God bless
appreciate it
David can you explain what Biden's
jurisdiction is on this case yeah
absolutely none this has nothing to do
with Biden Biden has no jurisdiction
here
timing is perfect the cancel is canceled
and the orange will be wearing orange
says John thank you John should we be
sending Trump thoughts and prayers with
the understanding of their effectiveness
absolutely
jaded says Don Jr's nasal nasal paths
sound completely unusable now they
really do let's listen to Ellie honig
and see what's going on very well there
are all sorts of underground tunnels
garages that is a law enforcement heavy
area I do not expect to see him being
perp walked as they say or walked out on
the street by law enforcement I agree
virtually certain they will bring him in
through one of those underground
entrances he will then have to be
fingerprinted and they don't use ink
anymore really you just sort of put your
hand on a computer screen he will have a
mug shot taken and here in New York
state wolf it's really important to know
bug shots are not presumptively public
they're not automatically public the law
here says that if there's some specific
law enforcement need then the law then
the mug shot can be made public usually
that means The Fugitive type situation
someone on the run so we'll see what the
decision is there another question is
will he be handcuffed ordinarily in the
course of an arraignment before the
person comes into court they would be
briefly handcuffed but I think that can
be negotiated around here we'll see what
the secret service has to say at the
arraignment itself here's what will
happen the judge will advise Donald
Trump of the charges against him Donald
Trump will enter his initial plea which
almost certainly will be not guilty the
judge will make sure that Donald Trump
has a lawyer and has a lawyer of his
choosing I'm sure that will be that will
be the case and then the judge will set
some of the next dates sometimes a trial
date will be set but sometimes judges
won't set a trial date at that first
hearing they'll set the date for legal
motions and discovery which is the
exchange of information right those are
the next steps that we're going to look
to see in the courthouse they will all
be very very dramatic indeed bringing
grass I know you're working your sources
on the security preparations that are
underway in New York City specifically
in New York right now I see people
tuning in and saying David is this
really happening and the answer is that
yes it is it is really happening
um we are doing our best to keep up with
all of it and hearing from so many of
you
um Chandler says happy fifth anniversary
to me and Happy First presidential
indictment day
Evan says I heard when the grand jury
was Voting there were massive dumps at
the last minute I heard the same
war machine says I can't wait to see
Trump on the witness stand with tears in
his eyes I doubt this ever goes to trial
does this mean infrastructure week will
be delayed again you know Stephen I
think it might be I really do
icon is listening to YouTube's beautiful
day
um if there is a God this narcissist POS
will go to prison like he deserves
Rudd with a 50 Super Chat who's the
right Wings George Soros given that
their accusations have so reliably been
confessions there must be some rich
right-wing or Puppeteer behind
everything please put this towards your
website update fund maybe the Koch
brothers I don't know I don't think
there is really a right-wing equivalent
of Soros
Justin says Candace and others attack on
you deserve a big come on guys choice of
Pac-Man responds because they are liars
they are
Greg says to think that anything the GOP
or Trump says in good faith is a serious
misunderstanding of reality in
jurisprudence it is
Mr Scott says let's be clear today the
right agrees with one fact Trump was
indicted from here on out they will
craft their own reality that brings this
back to woke Brown Jewish trans persons
they will indeed let me say one thing
I I'm aware I'm getting all sorts of
messages that both the twitch and
YouTube streams
are getting overrun with the trolls that
have found that that have come across me
over the last three days as Don Jr Sean
Hannity Candace Owens Michael Knowles
Matt Walsh and others have led a hate
mob against me I'm aware that it's
happening in the chat uh moderators are
Banning people when they notice it and
do guys do whatever you want Trump's
been indicted okay Trump's been indicted
that's the reason we're here
uh you guys are very boring very very
very boring
thanks to Harry for giving out five
twitch subscriptions thanks to people
like Splash Mock and others who also
have subscribed I see three of you
today's coupon code is indicted if you
can do anything today to support
Independent Media let it be to go to
joinpakman.com let it be let it be and
sign up with the coupon code indicted I
have an additional one two three
four four five six seven people to thank
putting us at 190.
remember if you can't afford even the
discounted memberships you can request a
free one at
davidpackman.com free membership the
memberships include
extra content every day including of
course the world famous bonus show let's
listen to Adam kinzinger weighing in on
this historic historic day I don't think
I'm not really surprised by the
indictment but I think like everybody
I'm surprised it came down now I think
we all expected we were going to have a
month Obama to sit back as we figured
out what happens but I think this took
you know by all indications the former
president vice prize took a lot of us by
surprise and it seems like it's probably
fairly well planned out because if it
takes you by surprise from a security
perspective uh that's probably a good
thing
so what do you anticipate we'll see next
well I mean look you're going to see
certainly the president the former
president come out fighting whatever he
can or can't say I'm not sure what's
going to be limited to him when you're
under an indictment but certainly he'll
come out and try to win the court of
public opinion this is the first of
potentially many other indictments on
the way as well which uh the uh you do a
pretty bad summer for the former
president but I think within the party
within the Republican party this isn't
necessarily going to hurt him I do think
it is going to hurt him and the general
electorate and the people that are you
know obviously sick of this drama uh but
he's going to continue to fight I'm sure
oh yeah I think we all need to remember
for those of us that are concerned about
the future of this country and concerned
about the future of the Republican party
this doesn't mean that the you know the
threat I guess to democracy is over uh
we still have to continue to see that
with a clearance oh guys oh my goodness
Trump just put out an all-caps rant
where he says he's been indicated rather
than indicted any oh my goodness oh this
I I've got to pull this up truth
essential
I can't believe it it's it's just too
much I might have to retire I might have
to retire look at this oh my God look at
this these Thugs and radical left
monsters have just indicated the 45th
president of the United States of
America
and the leading Republican candidate by
far for the 2024 nomination for
president caps lock engage this is an
attack on our country the likes of which
has never been seen before it is
likewise A continuing attack on our once
free and fair elections the USA is now a
third world nation a nation in serious
decline so sad
um I think I should just screenshot this
uh yeah let's just capture that I'm
going to need that
I'm going to need that very very
strongly
for uh various different elements folks
it is it's becoming beyond belief at
this point that the former president was
indicted he did not commit any crimes
they say we will vigorously fight this
political prosecution in court Trump's
attorneys have taken an aggressive
stance they have pushed back multiple
times during these investigations
particularly here in the DA's office
remember they went to the Supreme Court
twice to fight the D.A from obtaining
the former president's tax return so
their posture is one that they are going
to fight this case they're saying he
didn't commit any crime sure and they're
going to fight this in court well
it's going to be an amazing amazing
development in U.S history uh
you know it's interesting David we're
just hearing and I'm anxious to get your
thoughts that Trump is already
fundraising on the basis of this
criminal charge these indict this
indictment of course it does not take
long right and I don't think uh this
will surprise anyone but he blasted out
a fundraising appeal with the New York
Times he's blasting all right here is
attorney Alina Haba we have to see this
what is his state of mind about this
12 Braden Brett I think we all are
all our um
the pathetic case that we've seen yeah
um and just knowing the facts as I know
them based on comments to repressed by
people like Michael Cohen who they're
resting their case on I think his
sentiments are that this is the result
of him leading in the polls doing
incredibly well
um he is the leading candidate there is
quite literally no evidence of that but
I want to tell you something else guys
DeSantis
is doing better
against Biden than Trump in the polls
why would Democrats if we want to follow
their logic why would Democrats do
something that they presumably
presumably believe would hurt Trump
since that would help DeSantis who is
doing better
against Biden than Trump
if if you want to argue this is
Democrats
they should be helping Trump not doing
something to hurt him because of course
none of it makes any sense they're just
making it up no and when people are
afraid of someone being successful and
fixing the mess that our history is they
come after you so this is the same thing
that President Trump has been dealing
with
years it's really not this is actually
the first time that this specific thing
is going on super chats are just coming
in so fast one question is do I think
this will become a national holiday that
would be cool
I would go for that indicated for cafe
or indicated because of Obama asking for
a family member hard to know when this
indictment Trump finally wins a popular
vote indicated promo code yeah
oh God it's just so insane
the value attainment guy's head must be
exploding right now amazing job in that
interview masterfully held your own
company thank you gracias
um
okay I just wanted to go to something
oh yeah welcome everybody I mean Trump's
been indicted I see people saying is
this is it for real this time it is
it is for Real
uh by the way if you're watching on
YouTube and you want to hit that
subscribe button do you see what's
happening this thing is like a slot
machine what's happening on the YouTube
channel
since Don Jr went after me it's just
been look at this thing
it's just constantly rolling
I think I just did I just get bar all
the way across or seven I never
understood what Barr meant on slot
machines by the way no but in all
seriousness if you're watching right now
uh please do hit that subscribe button
it's free and it really tells YouTube
send some people this guy's way send
some people this guy's way why not you
know I I honestly am in shock every time
I look up it's just there's another 10.
look at these numbers folks
it's an historic day it really is
this is you know where I learned
actually about this
take a look at the oranges of the
investigation the the oranges of YouTube
were when jenk euger said you should
really get on there okay Trump likely to
be arraigned next week let's listen
inaccurately on Truth social that he was
going to be arrested last Tuesday which
obviously as we now know did not know so
they certainly are using this for that
Advantage one other thing I'll say to
watch here is we we're still waiting to
see what these charges look like we have
no idea what they look like they are
still under seal we don't know what
legal Theory precisely Alvin Bragg is
going to be pursuing we have an idea but
we don't actually know other people who
don't know though are these
Congressional Republicans these are the
Republicans three of them who are
chairman in the house right now that
sent that letter demanding testimony and
documents from Alvin Bragg something
that has caused a lot of consternation
behind the scenes in the Republican
party because there are Republicans who
don't believe that they have the Merit
to go and ask a local prosecutor to come
and testify before Congress they noted
then you know these charges had not even
come down yet when these three chairmen
sent that letter to Alvin Bragg but I
had found out that the reason in part
why they sent that was because Trump was
upset that more Republicans were not out
there publicly defending him questioning
the merits of the case and actually
using it that's right their power and
control of the house on Capitol Hill to
do something about it and so we saw that
letter that came from several of these
chairmen where that ultimately ends up
it remains to be seen because I mean
they they sent a lot of requesting
testimony before an indictment had even
happened and so that is a big part of
this as well to keep an eye on not just
how Trump responds to this but also
Republicans who were in power on Capitol
Hill
now let me get Ellie honig into this uh
Ellie do you have a sense now about
these charges that are going to be made
public at least at some point we know
that Trump is being criminally indicted
right now we don't know the specific
charges we don't know if they're
misdemeanors we don't know if they're
felonies but what do you sense right
well so just looking at the known fact
pattern and applying that to New York
state law it looks like one of the
potentially of course we've not seen if
a potentially applicable crimes here
would be called falsification of
business records that means basically
the Trump organization in its internal
record-keeping falsely logged this 130
000 hush money payment to Stormy Daniels
as a legal fee if prosecutors can prove
that and remember prove that Donald
Trump himself was part of the way that
that payment was logged that's a
misdemeanor which means the maximum
penalty is one year but realistically
wolf nobody's going to go to prison for
a first-time misdemeanor of that nature
correct the charges can get more serious
under New York law if prosecutors can
tie the fall falsification of business
records to some other crime to some
second crime and so that's one of the
big questions that I'm waiting to see is
what will they allege as the second
crime it could be a campaign Finance
violation that's been the gist of a lot
of the reporting and the theory would be
that this payment to Stormy Daniels was
actually the same as a campaign donation
or a campaign expenditure right it would
have been far in excess of the legal
limits but there's a big legal problem
there which is we're talking about a
federal campaign and federal campaign
laws that govern the campaign for the
president but we're talking about New
York state law and it's not at all clear
that New York state law could cover a
federal campaign
let me go to Kristen Holmes Kristen I
understand you're getting more
information right now what are you
hearing yeah I'm talking to sources who
are close to the former president this
actually goes back to what we were
talking about with David Charlie and
just a moment ago and what exactly the
political implication is of this and
essentially what they are saying is that
they aren't really sure that yes they do
believe that this could potentially help
him in a contested primary but they're
not sure what this looks like in the
long term they understand that these
legal complications might make him so
polarizing that they could hurt him in a
general election but I do want to point
out one thing and this is when we talk
about the contested primary when we talk
about where Trump's base is I was in
Waco with Trump on Saturday there were
at least 10 000 people there this was
with a indictment a potential indictment
looming we talked to dozens of people in
the crowd asking them if former
president Trump was to be indicted do
you think that this would impact his
political career his chances that being
president would it affect the way you
think about him okay so I think that the
takeaway they're getting to is one I've
been mentioning for a while which is I
think the indictment helps Trump in the
primary but does not help him in the
general if indeed he is the the
Republican nominee and I from what I've
been hearing from many of you uh that's
also that's also what you think there
were not people are pointing out there
were not ten thousand people at the
rally yeah there were between 3 500 and
5 000 people at the rally
um let's listen to Manu Raju friend of
the show by the way from the Republican
leadership is that right yeah the
speaker of the house just weighing in
here indicating that he plans to use the
power of His House Majority to go after
the prosecutor in this case Alvin Brown
now he just released a statement via
Twitter saying that Bragg has in his
view irreparably damaged our country
contending that Bragg is trying to quote
interfere in our presidential election
he went on to criticize Bragg's record
and Prosecuting criminals in New York
and then he said the American people
will not tolerate this Injustice and the
House of Representatives will hold Alvin
Bragg there you go unprecedented abuse
so they're investigating big Tech
they're investigating the weaponization
of government they're going to
investigate falchi as they often
pronounce it and now they're going to
investigate Alvin Bragg it's really
going to be fantastic I can assure you
folks I am so humbled and flattered at
the people who are signing up with the
coupon code indicted we we may soon hit
our goal of 250 let me see here Jay
Morgan uh as well as a whole bunch of
other people one two three four five six
we have too much going on 9 10
um to name everybody but I am going to
count everybody 11 12 13 14 15
16 17 18 19 and 20 as well as 21 21 plus
195. uh puts us at uh 116. I'm sorry
216. also huge thank you to everyone
supporting over on Twitch including
people donating multiple gifted
memberships tiny sir Jen and some others
five six seven two twenty three I don't
even know where we are here on these
numbers but it is crazy thanks to Eric
Valdez let's look at a couple other
super chats Jacob says support and
solidarity to you David from a fellow
leftist thank you Jacob
thanks for the live stream says stuff
I'm new here but it seems like a good
time to tip my server thank you Aram
very much appreciate that I just want to
say Trump a lump a ding dong wow
Trump put out a truth a bit ago where he
misspelled indicted as indicated he did
yeah we talked about it Gwyneth Paltrow
won her case nobody cares stay safe
David yeah I can't stand Gwyneth Paltrow
and she's a complete lunatic when it
comes to the health disinformation but
the case against her was very very shaky
and I watched a bunch of clips from that
let's check in on Newsmax and see how
Newsmax is doing this guy went after me
this guy Rob Murphy this this clown he
sent the hate mob after me two days ago
into the first president to be indicted
in the history of this country Alvin
Bragg and his cronies are popping
champagne bottles tonight this right I
don't think so sir and it's not going to
last very long the first indictment ever
for a former president and they make
this unprecedented and totally political
move with one of the most ridiculous
alleged crimes you could ever imagine an
allegation that's been looked at several
times and laughed at including by
Merrick Garland's Department of Justice
political As It Gets the allegation that
Trump's 130 thousand dollar payment to
porn star Stormy Daniels was an illegal
campaign contribution
that's the allegation that's the first
indictment ever it's pretty reasonable
actually of the United States welcome to
the clown show the derangement has come
to a fever pitch it is clear that is the
case Alvin Bragg the I've never seen
this guy's show he's genuinely out of
his mind like very very sick General is
soon going to be humiliated and will be
remembered as the man who gave absolute
Rocket Fuel to Donald Trump as he ran
for president again
the ultimate unforced error by the
salivating hacks who would do anything
to destroy the former president who
threat this is pretty spicy I have to
say elitist government with populism
they will never forgive him for
introducing that in this country trigger
this case against Trump was clearly
barely strong enough to manage even an
indictment which again you only need
half the grand jury plus one to get an
indictment that's why they say you can
indict a ham sandwich you just need half
plus one and in Manhattan you could
probably indict Donald Trump for driving
25 into 25. whoa think about the Optics
of this a radical left-wing district
attorney funded by a billionaire
militant Marxist has convinced a grand
jury to indict the lead I'm not going to
do it again but as we've explained now
many times
the connection between Soros and Bragg
is very very distant hammering the
competition right now in the next
Presidential contest is indicted here is
a tweet from the New York Post from five
hours ago before the indictment was
announced showing Trump surging up 30
points over to Santa's what they won't
tell you is that that's good for
Democrats Trump does worse against Biden
Trump does worse against Biden I don't
even know what who's the source here oh
this is McLaughlin yeah these are
literal trash polls a lot of people use
these as toilet paper
um in serious polling DeSantis does
better than Trump against Biden and this
is all was that the cat turd poll is it
possible that's what that was
um
big thanks to Doug Jones for signing up
at joinpakman.com folks I think we're
going to open phones at 250 and see
what's on people's minds so uh grab
those memberships let's see some other
super chats happy indictment day I
interviewed a former white nationalist I
met in a comment in one of your videos
that sounds weird and dangerous be safe
out there
they are oh no I don't use the term butt
hurt is homophobic I don't use that
hopefully this is the first of several
indictments let's hope
sir I'm happy you're handling this
right-wing attack and stride and so well
explaining your side of things
intelligently thank you David thank you
David I very very much appreciate that
that is an exciting thing to hear from
you
uh let's see what is happening over here
with Aaron Burnett out front
is this the lead story I wonder
CNN breaking news
good evening I'm Aaron Burnett out front
tonight the breaking news and it is
historic former president Donald J Trump
has been indicted by a New York grand
jury investigating hush money payments
to adult film star Stormy Daniels it is
the first time in American history that
a current or former president is facing
criminal charges and here's the first
Super Chat apparently from someone who
has become sexually excited by this
indictment which is certainly
interesting to hear not something I
necessarily expected I have to admit
thanks to Melissa for re-upping your
Twitch Prime subscription folks twitch
welcome it's so great to be on Twitch
right now and seeing everybody here it's
been tremendous to see everybody oh
other people are aroused they say on
Twitch I guess okay so you're not the
only one
uh interesting
um Daniel says David sir I'm coming to
you with tears in my eyes tears of joy
I'm sure I'm sure that those are of
course tears of joy
um will I open the phones yes I will
open the phones if we get to 250 new
members bitter IPA becomes number 238
with the twitch Prime subscription let's
check in on Fox News oh it's bongino
folks look at this it is bongino Hyundai
Santa Cruz versus Subaru Outback Jesus
is horrible someone we have no idea who
it is and you know I heard a liberal on
this network before too as well say
which I thought was the most telling
statement because and she may have been
sitting right next to you it was really
incredible why is he screaming not here
to defend herself to be fair but it's
funny when they say the quiet part out
loud she said you know this is going to
be really powerful it makes me feel
powerful because it's going to be like
this asterisk on Donald Trump forever
and I thought man did you just sum up
liberalism there you go right there you
need that power don't you you needed
this understand that bongino is a figure
within the the right
that is seen by some as a thinker
I know
I know I know guys trust me I know the
probably the greatest Freudian slip ever
you've handed him in a diamond while
handing him the nomination at the same
time you may have just I don't know I
mean I don't want to get out ahead of my
skis there's a lot of time here but I
can tell you everything he has said to
people about they're not coming for you
uh they're not they're coming for me
because I'm in the way now you look at
this tonight and you're like yeah that
kind of sounds right to me you're gonna
break 200 years of U.S precedent about
indicting your political opponents over
a business records charge that happened
seven years ago we don't know what the
charges are yet what is bongino talking
about huh it's what you got that's what
you're gonna do You're Gonna Roll with
that yeah because you want an asterisk
they're absolutely gonna do that and
Jessica who is sitting next to me the
way I saw what she said was she said
that this felt too powerful oh it felt
strong and not that she enjoyed enjoyed
the strength of indicting a former
president I felt she was saying it maybe
was Overkill we'll have to ask her how
she really feels about it she's not here
to defend it she's not here to defend
herself but but never stopped them
before regardless listen I don't care
because I'm not playing cutesy time I'm
really I'm the wrong host I really don't
care uh I just I I can't stand liberals
and I can't take them anymore and I'm
serious I you know she should have
spoken out like every other liberal and
said listen I don't like this guy I
think maybe we can beat him at The
Ballot Box whatever happened happened
seven years ago the hard reality is you
know he's a former president running for
president right now against the guy in
the white house uh this was a charge
drop by actually he's running a primary
he first has to win the primary I think
would be to run this election the way
elections are run which is not out of a
jail cell with guns pointed at your
political opponents like they do in the
third world you know maybe that's kind
of something you might want to say I'm
just going to throw that out there I
mean you have an opportunity to do the
right thing I mean yeah you know what's
ironic you have actual evidence of a
criminal Enterprise Joe Biden Inc is
running in conjunction with the business
partner but it's kind of strange you
know you don't hear me on the air every
night screaming for Joe Biden again
locked up and in peace I'd love to see
him impeach but we don't have the votes
right now so I don't wait
the entire movement he's a part of is
screaming for exactly those things every
day how they never miss an opportunity
to miss an opportunity
with the upper right is some is someone
about to show up there
uh I guess the only oh oh God it's Lara
Trump let's listen as it gets anybody
with a brain in their head knows that
Nancy Pelosi has been funneling secrets
about what's going to happen in the next
couple weeks to her husband so that they
can make loads of money off of stocks
when you look at the tracker when you
look at the stocks that Pelosi buys when
you look at the things that Pelosi knows
right before Paul Pelosi goes out and
buys a stock you know there's corruption
there those are the top two Democrats in
Washington or at least these people are
really horrible like really really
really really horrible
um all right we are at 246 out of 50. I
know we're going to get to 250. so I am
going to open phone lines right now via
Discord I want to hear from you folks
what do you think about the indictment
of the failed former president Donald
Trump just don't make me look stupid
with the 250 I've never gone in ahead of
time with confidence like this because
it is risky don't make me look dumb
that's all I'm asking let's make sure we
get to the 250. we are going to use
Discord at davidpackman.com
Discord join the waiting Lobby
let's get that going
let's start and we will call it Trump
indicted
and then I will be hearing from some
people here I think is going to be
absolutely fantastic let's get it all
right there is by staying dumping in
five memberships via twitch which gets
us there thank you thank you for making
it so that I am not humiliated
um folks
this is gonna be nuts uh let's see what
is happening davidpackman.com Discord I
want to hear from you I you need to do
me a favor though get right to your
point because so many people want to
weigh in we're going to start with
Samuel who is a website member Samuel
thank you sir for your support at
joinpakman.com what's on your mind today
hi David can you hear me perfectly well
oh you're British
yes yeah I I just sent you a Super Chat
I'm the guy from San Andreas I love it
yes yeah uh how are you doing I'm doing
well
good good good to hear um so yeah my my
question is
um I'm currently studying uh terrorism
studies at the University of Saint
Andrews really you know one of the
things I'm concerned about is do you
believe that you know all the you know
the chaos that will ensue from the the
indictment there's never been a better
time to get away with a great deal of
you know right-wing terrorism in in the
US I am concerned about that I am
concerned about that and obviously that
is I mean listen I don't want it to
happen people right Wingers keep writing
to me saying David you're praying for
violence and Terror no I'm hoping none
of that happens I hope that the Maga
people just go hey you know what he got
indicted because the grand jury decided
there was evidence and that it doesn't
lead to that sort of thing but I'm I am
concerned
yeah I mean it it it's quite priming to
be honest yeah yeah yeah and I you know
I was reading or you know on a different
matter I was reading your uh tweet and
all the reaction you've been getting to
it yep all right so I just I just think
this whole
you know coming you know a foreigner
looking in you know to what's going on
in the US
um you know all this all talk about you
know thoughts and prayers thoughts and
prayers well it's just not good enough
it's not good enough yeah you know it's
just so Uncle you know Kyle Kolinski
said it he said
it's it's just so benign what I said
it's just the thoughts and prayers don't
work they didn't prevent the shooting
they don't do anything after the shoot
the period that's it it's not really
controversial
no it's not I I just I'm just tired of
it you know yeah you know especially
when it's you know it's it's kids being
gunned down you know in these schools
and you know that you think that that
would be
I mean just from a rational perspective
you think that that would be enough to
you know change to come about and you'd
think it would anger them more than my
tweet you know but it's it's really wild
stuff I think it did in a sense backfire
on them because every one of our
platforms is blowing up yes we have to
go through and delete all these
anti-semitic messages and it's annoying
but in the long run it's it's
meaningless and they really help boost
our platform and if we get the
advertisers back we'll be we'll be you
know everybody will be none the wiser
yeah that'd be great and then one one
final point you know uh speaking of
anti-Semitism I just don't understand
this this obsession with with George
Soros yeah I don't get it I don't get it
he is just the perfect Fall Guy for so
many different flavors of conspiracy
theories uh about Jews about One World
Government about Elites about build the
it just it's too perfect for them they
can't get away from it ignoring the fact
that the guy's 92.
it's unbelievable it really is I first
time I I heard about Soros was um Alex
Jones I mean he's been pushing Soros for
years you know he's this you know uh
sort of great linchpin and I I I think
it personally I think it all comes from
this you know the the dark hearts of the
anti-semites it's it's got nothing to do
with you know him personally
um but you know he's just a sort of um
the target he you know he's like you say
he's he's become the sort of
um the figurehead if you like it's
absolutely it's just it's just horrid
stuff and I I I hate it it's just it's
horrible it's horrible all right well
thank you for the call I very much
appreciate hearing from you there's been
some movement here at the courthouse
let's see what this is so this is not
ever gonna stick the president's not
going to go to prison for okay uh well
someone is going somewhere I guess
that's what's going on and uh we'll
continue hearing from folks why don't we
go next to Jeff from Rochester Jeff
welcome to the program wow what a day
what a day Jeff from Rochester as soon
as you accept my invitation we'll be
able to hear from you
uh Jeff from Rochester welcome
can you hear me David yes I can
oh okay cool this is my very first time
ever using Discord I love it I just
joined uh
your website last week thank you and
yeah it was I've been listening you know
I started I'm a teacher and I started
listening to your show during the
pandemic because I was teaching over
Zoom yep and uh I'm a social studies
teacher love it 31 years
um I work with incarcerated uh kids
um
and uh
we've we've been strongly affected by
that raise the age thing I know you want
me to get right to my question
um I didn't think today would ever come
I really was totally convinced that they
were never actually going to indict uh
the former president yeah and uh
I don't know uh are you a fan of Stephen
Colbert at all if you ever let's watch a
show never quite I have no problem with
the guy I just don't have time to watch
anything you know
yeah I understand
um
and I would you know he won't say the
former president's name I was just
always wondering what you thought of
that I didn't know that's interesting no
I mean it's uh I mean I don't have I
don't really have too much to say about
it it's it's it's curious I would uh do
you know why he won't say it he just
calls him what the former guy the last
guy
he calls him uh the former the former
president or uh the you know or uh you
know the the the four he doesn't he
doesn't go like where you say like the
failed form right which I like yeah
that's interesting I'll check it out but
no I have no thoughts on that sounds uh
sounds cutesy yeah he he he he made well
you know he got kind of famous during
the uh during his administration for
cons for doing what I thought was a
pretty good impression
all right Jeff from Rochester sounds
like your dog got out so I'm Gonna Let
You Go very much appreciate your support
very very important stuff uh I think
kind of off I uh all right let's go to
Jonathan from Tucson Arizona folks
please get right to your question we've
got so many different people here
waiting to chat Jonathan from Tucson
welcome
hello hey
oh hey how you doing buddy
uh you know been part of your uh website
Channel since 2021 it was like three
days before the January six rights wow
yeah it was uh that was a weird time it
was indeed it was if it's also my 30th
birthday and during uh covid-19 I
couldn't really do much fair
I I the my point like uh coming towards
the
Riot that happened at uh the senate or
the capital
this was like three days before the
10-year Mark of the shooting that
happened here in Tucson Arizona 2010
this was the one where Gabrielle
Giffords was shot in the head by Jerry
Lee lochner right I hope you remember I
do I do remember it
um
I
um every time I see
crazy things happening like such as this
Riot and this these crazy people out
doing the protesting especially here in
Arizona for Maricopa to about say about
Cochise
um
I think that the 2010 shooting was
probably like the more modern
introduction towards what's happening
right now with like the state of the
Republican party and their supporters
just how violent they can be but even
though they said Jared Lee Loughner was
not
um any form of political party I made
I'm sure
Jonathan you really are giving great
backstory but did you have a question
today
I just want to know like where do you
think all of this
um like
paranoia started
paranoia
um I would say from like uh Republican
party supporters
from from the Republican voters paranoia
well listen here I'm not sure I
understand Jonathan but here's the thing
right-wing voters are far more motivated
by fear than our left-wing voters and
thus with fear
comes reactionary thinking in many many
cases and that is a fundamental
difference between those on the left and
those on the right I don't know if that
gets directly to your question but I do
appreciate you calling in and we're
going to continue hearing from people
here how about Sean from Atlanta Sean
from Atlanta welcome to the program uh
what is on your mind today sir
Sean from Atlanta yeah I've invited you
to participate you do have to accept in
order for people to be able to hear you
that would be the next step to accept
the invitation and then folks will be
able to hear you thanks for the
continued subscriptions using the coupon
code indicted Sean you're connected but
now you've muted yourself if you can
unmute yourself I will be able to hear
you okay
I'm sorry David hi what's on your mind
today can you hear me yes
hi so um well
um
uh really well first off I'm
a bit mix about the Trump's indictment
you know today
didn't think it would actually come
honestly
but my question really um I guess I will
have is um
so some another issue that spelled my
mind has been the California Senate race
going on
so um
I guess so you know how Barbara Lee
Katie Porter and Adam Schiff are really
The Big Three who
um they could either go for in that race
yes I do so I'm really for
Barbara Lee and Katie Porter
um I was in more so for Katie Porter for
a while because
she's younger personally and I have the
mentality of like just how divide our
country is that it would be better to
have younger people someone with more
energy and who can relate to the voters
for a longer period of time but after
Katie Porter's comments
um in support of Netanyahu I'm starting
to
it it gave me a bit of a negative
um you know it left a bad taste in my
mouth in a way
Sean I'm going to be interviewing
hopefully all three of them we've
already interviewed Schiff we are
working on Barbara Lee and then
hopefully Katie Porter will be on I have
not taken a position on that race I also
am not a California voter and I am not a
supporter of Netanyahu so that's
basically like everything I could
possibly say about that race
okay okay well he kind of just answered
my question so thank you so much
appreciate it there is Sean from Atlanta
and folks if I need more information to
answer the question I'll ask you for it
you know
um you you feel free to get right to the
question and then I'll help you help me
fill in the facts as needed let's go to
Chris from Texas Chris from Texas
welcome to the program Donald Trump has
been indicted he will be arraigned next
week what is on your mind today on this
very very special day
Chris from Texas you've got to accept
the invitation folks who are waiting to
talk to me but they have looked just
like a nickname or something like that
you're not going to get called on you
got to have like name in town or town
Chris welcome what's going on
Chris you've muted yourself now please
unmute
all right can you hear me sir yes I can
all right sorry about that so I actually
wrote my question down because I'm
pretty sure I was going to forget it
beautiful um we welcome that I have a
two-part question okay uh my first
question is why is Mega not more excited
about the indictment
seeing how everybody keeps talking about
this is just going to help them in the
polls right and my second question is if
Ron uh Ron DeSantis sent out a tweet
saying that he's not going to really
uh assist with the extradition
um how would that actually play out
if he's not going to help well so two
parts one why is Maga not more excited
about the indictment if they actually
believe that it's good it's because they
don't actually believe that it's good
it's it's actually quite risky it might
be good it might not be good it might
help Trump in the primary I think it'll
hurt him in the general so these are
really good questions they're not that
excited even though they say it'll be
good because they don't really believe
it'll be good they're not sure and by
the way this is how you do a call Chris
okay I hope every this is exactly how
you do a call second question
um the extradition from Florida I don't
know what Des Sanctus said but Trump
through lawyers has already said he will
surrender so it's just not going to be a
factor
okay oh thank you so much I really
appreciate you uh answering my questions
a plus caller Chris from Texas thank you
sir
yes sir all right Chris from is it folks
he was polite sure
sorry sir got right to the questions had
him written down I mean really you can't
ask for more you you truly cannot let's
go next to Jason from Chicago Jason from
Chicago welcome let's see if you can do
just as well here
Jason we're connected you're not muted
but you have the wrong audio device
selected please select the correct audio
device and then I will be able to hear
you
Jason you have now muted yourself which
isn't going to get us any closer
slightly
Jason
all right no Jason that's too bad let's
go to D from Virginia D welcome to the
program how are you this evening
D you're on the air
can you hear him yes I can
okay so hold on I got a question hold on
I had to roll down let me go to it
please
what would it take like worst case
scenario for lawmakers to act on guns
and uh part two if you don't feel
comfortable you don't necessarily have
to answer it do you own a gun
so on the second part I have not talked
publicly about whether or not I own guns
and I've it's just a decision I just
don't talk about I'll talk about policy
it's I just don't I just don't talk
about that
what would it take for lawmakers to do
to actually do something I really hate
to say this okay when I think about like
what would it really take
I think it would take them being
personally connected to a tragedy at the
hands of guns and even then some of them
may not change their minds
that is crazy and part of it is
they are funded by the NRA and their
voters wouldn't like it if they took
positions like mine on guns so sadly I
don't know I don't know that there's
anything quite frankly I think we need
to get different rather than changing
the minds of the people currently in
power D I think we need to put people in
power who will actually do something
different
right right okay well I think that's
pretty much it that's one of that
question I appreciate appreciate it
thank you for having the question
written down and getting right to it
some folks are doing they're really
doing the thing and I love it
um a couple more memberships dumped in
via the website putting us at 277.
thanks to the freak and Kathy via twitch
which pushes us to 279 the goal is 350.
we are hearing from people all over the
country and all over the world let's go
to Brittany from Texas Brittany welcome
to the David Pacman show live stream
Donald Trump has been indicted we are
talking to people including you what is
on your mind Brittany
oh boy we're on a delay of some kind
Brittany you've got to listen in Discord
because we're on a delay I can hear my
voice in the background there
can you hear me now yes I can
okay awesome hi
um so I was wondering do you think that
Donald Trump is
um
usually late to his rallies and stuff
because he wants to see like the crowd
size like that does something for him oh
yeah Brittany you are very very much
spotted there's a couple different
things here it's a power move number one
Trump uh by being late and keeping
people waiting and building anticipation
it's a power move by the way beautiful
audio quality I have to say Brittany uh
secondly
um he is we know that like on the plane
he watches the crowd and uh you know he
I I do think that it is something Trump
kind of gets off on for sure he's
extraordinarily narcissistic he he likes
knowing people are waiting on him uh I
think that there's I think that that is
exactly what it is and to be honest
there are suspicions that
it that he just runs late because they
leave late and and people speculate
about why is it you know bathroom
related or whatever we don't really know
but it also seems like he gets on the
plane late already and that sets him
back significantly
yeah I just can't imagine like waiting
first of all waiting I can't imagine
going it's crazy to a rally but I
definitely can't imagine just sitting
there and being like Oh I wonder when
he's gonna show up I wonder when it's
when you think about that you realize
how depraved the folks are right because
you think okay so they they sometimes
drive from hours away they get there
five hours before the rally they go
through security it's the crap fair food
that they have to deal with oftentimes
it's direct sun with literally no shade
they've got the fetid Sani cans then
Trump is two hours late and then within
10 minutes of him speaking the crowds
often board already and then when they
leave it's like a mess and there's mud
everywhere and it's just crazy it really
takes a special person to even engage
with the with an event like that
yeah I agree
um and just one more question
um mangoes in your area are they high
right now mangoes are pretty so I have
to I have to admit this Brittany
recently I've switched to Frozen mango
chunks and before you cancel me I'm
going to tell you why
um it is a little difficult to time when
a mango is ripe in the sense that I
might not want it for like 24 hours
after it's ripe and then by then it
starts getting wrinkly and now I've
missed it and now I've missed it so so I
have to admit particularly with it being
kind of winter-ish
um I have been getting the value size
organic mango chunks I'll when I know I
want them the next morning as part of my
fruit salad with my breakfast I will um
put I'll move them from the freezer to
the fridge along with some wild
blueberries and raspberries and then
it's ready for me I'll throw a little
chia pudding in there scramble an egg
and I'm good to go
absolutely well thank you sir for taking
my call my pleasure ma'am I appreciate
it very much folks that may be the best
caller in history when you consider
getting right to her question following
up with a food question as well as also
um audio quality like I've never seen
before I actually think that that may be
the best caller in history and I know
that that's going to be offensive to
many others but it is what it is okay
thank you very much let's go next to
Rudy from Fresno Rudy from Fresno
welcome to the program what's on your
mind today can you possibly outdo that
last call
no boy
Rudy from Fresno welcome to the show you
need only accept my invitation and
everybody will be able to hear you I
don't know if I cannot do that but I
guess what's been on my mind please is
how
Rudy you're coming through loud and
clear please continue the question I
wasn't sure okay what's been on my mind
as I watch this play out is again how
um how black Americans seem to be
carrying the weight in this country
right
um what do you mean brag brag and
Leticia James and the courage it takes
to actually follow through with these
and the burden that we always place on
black Americans
um
um and just by doing the right thing you
know when we talk about black lives
matter the Civil Rights Movement all of
those things
um that's just you know a thought I've
been having but what do you think do you
just personally do you think that
anything will come from the doj
investigations I have honestly no idea
at this point I'm done predicting here
my only prediction is Trump won't do a
day of prison time that prediction I'm
feeling very confident in any others I
would honestly just be be blowing smoke
Rudy and I don't want to do that to you
okay thank you fair all right there is
Rudy let's go to Braden from beautiful
Connecticut Braden welcome to the
program what's on your mind today
not much how's it going David nice to
talk to you going well likewise
uh I've just got one question for you um
let's say theoretically that you know
he's not charged and it just happens
um do you think that this may end up uh
hurting Democrats in the 2024 election
well hold on Trump's going to be charged
are you saying he's not convicted
oh sorry uh convicted oh yeah
um I think that this will not hurt
Democrats I think it will hurt Trump
because it just makes him seem
extraordinarily chaotic uh so no I I
don't think I really don't think this
will hurt Democrats
all right then thank you for answering
and um have a great day David all right
Brent Braden from Connecticut
uh there are a lot of people waiting
here let's check in with Haley from
Maryland formerly Haley from Georgia
Haley welcome how are you celebrating
today
Haley
Haley you're on the air
oh boy
Haley rarely has Tech problems
Haley
well that's really too bad Haley is
actually a great caller
uh so that's that's a shame Zach from
North Dakota welcome to the show what is
on your mind today sir
hey David
um what's on my mind is I'm in North
Dakota today it's actually interesting
for the second concurrent legislative
session the governor a GOP Governor Doug
burgum has vetoed anti-transgender
legislation and there's also speculation
that he's considering jumping into the
GOP Primary for 2024 and I'm curious do
you think there's any place in the GOP
or the Republican party for a candidate
to take those kinds of stances of not
deleting trans people and banning books
and having any success you know I don't
know how to answer that question for the
following reason
on the one hand there is a big appetite
for anti-trans
in the Republican party right now it's
the biggest Applause lines at every
event so that makes me think if you're
not going to do anti-trans you don't
have a shot in the modern Republican
party on the other hand there are the
Mitt Romney types who are not pleased
with the anti-trans obsession and they
they might go for it what I don't know
and it's an empirical question
what is the makeup of the Republican
party at this time how many of each of
those groups are there I just don't know
the answer
all right fair enough appreciate the
time all right Zach from North Dakota
great to hear from you why don't we go
next to Andy from Virginia Andy from
Virginia welcome to the program what's
on your mind today sir
hey what's up brother how you doing we
enjoyed you on uh Patrick David's
podcast oh thank you pleasure
um quick question and I apologize we'll
probably cover this in a video what's
the tie between the D.A and Zorro so
they're trying to draw okay so here's
the deal
the right is saying the D.A is quite
literally being puppeteered by George
Soros who is directing the investigation
into the indictment the truth of it is
George Soros funds dozens if not
hundreds of different programs one of
those programs is a group that helps
elect DA's all over the country and that
group among others
supported Alvin Bragg's candidacy
so uh very very thin yes it is it is
quite a weak connection as you were as
you were identifying
um and of course Alvin Bragg has never
spoken to Soros and on and on and on and
that that's that's really it that's the
whole thing
as thick as their you know as their
assumptions normally are so I appreciate
it man all right thank you very much
there goes Andy from Virginia and ladies
and gentlemen that is going to end
today's coverage Trump indicted and it
is all insane thank you to everyone who
has joined me this is going to be a
crazy week
and I look forward to seeing all of you
here with me and we'll be back tomorrow
with a new show and the entire thing see
everybody very soon